20:19 is drawing to a close so a better
time to look back at the year that
Nintendo has had I am Lucy James joined
by Tamora say hello and Kelly Peggy
hello it's time to grade that company
[Music]
let's start by talking about Nintendo's
exclusives they have had a great year I
would say in terms of things like
Pokemon Sun shield
Fire Emblem battery make it to astral
chain I've already said Fire Emblem
Luigi's Mansion Yoshi's crafted worlds
what were the big standouts for you
cally that's good well I would
definitely say Pokemon and it is at the
top of the mine because it just came out
so most recent one but anyone is talking
about it
you know it's been doing very very well
too
commercially which is you know it
attracted a lot of controversy I think
before release which is always
interesting because you know you haven't
played the game yet you don't actually
know what's gonna be like when you get
it and so I think pre-release
controversies can always be a little you
know not indicative of much at all
except for opinion public opinion and in
this case I think Nintendo really or
Game Freak is well really delivered a
fantastic
the first hardcore Pokemon game on
console you know this is we had let's go
Pikachu an Eevee last year a very
different kind of Pokemon game than this
those were specifically billed as you
know their their main series Pokemon
games but but geared toward a more
casual audience
and these are these are the Hartford
ones and they are so clearly geared
towards the competitive audience with
tons of quality of life fixes small
things that make a huge difference in
the life of a competitive player without
forgetting the people who just like to
play pokemon and it is a fantastic
journey like the Dyna maxing and those
Jim's is he is so exciting you get like
the people cheering for you I saw a
tweet that was like you know every other
Pokemon game you like went into the back
of a Planet Fitness and beat up some
adult and then yes I'm some like
teenager and in this you're like you're
it's really bombastic and exciting and
it fits the the TV the transition to TV
as well I think really well so yeah I
saw a video of someone who had taken
that crying meme and said like what it
feels like to live next to a Pokemon
Center Stadium it's just like the
distant sound of the music from a stay
exactly yeah it's I think it was really
successful I don't need every every
Pokemon in my Pokemon game I I liked
that it was manageable I think to meet
the main story more manageable and yes
their Pokemon I missed but it I I was
just so charmed and I am still playing
it I really loved it I'm over a hundred
hours in getting Pokemon ready it's the
most accessible competitive has ever
been and I think people are getting
interested in it for the first time like
properly because before they were just
too many barriers to entry and almost
all of them are are gone now so I yeah
just a fantastic first step for Pokemon
on to switch so a new platform and also
properly on
time was just an exclusive this I'm
gonna go over the weak mention three
just because after franchise that I feel
like a lot of people like but is not it
doesn't get the same kind of mainstream
or even like put on a pedestal in the
same way that a smash brothers word or a
you know a new merrier game would it's
always been trucking along and it's
quietly like one of the most charming
video game experiences that you can have
luigi is a incredibly lovable dork
always walk in the shadow of his older
brother but in these in these games
given his own time to shine and boy does
he's got his little vacuum Poltergust
and he's like sucking up ghosts and the
first one was on the Gamecube was a
really good game when they followed it
up of dark moon on the 3ds which was not
as perhaps sharply delivered it was
almost too geared towards the handheld
because like professor and gets
interrupting you constantly and it's
like yeah I'm gonna be sitting here
playing for this for three straight
hours you don't have to do it exactly
and this felt like a little more
considered in terms of how they designed
it or it's got some levels and each
one's got a theme so you can come at it
like play one floor a day and kind of
progress up the tower you've got really
interesting ways to kind of almost
combat ghosts and solve puzzles with the
new kind of gameplay interactions and
then you have go EEG who feels like a
interesting character in itself but also
a valuable addition for anyone who wants
to kind of team up interesting like
puzzle potential there and mechanically
speaking and you can do interesting
things with with the character if you're
Eve regards to whether you're playing
alone or with someone else but unlike a
you know Mary again we're just
collecting coins or you know helping you
know another player long and or you're
you feel like you're babysitting a
character Goethe feels like you give it
someone else and they'll feel like
they're genuinely plain
the game alongside you and then this is
Luigi being Luigi which is fine there's
like a scared little boy the year of
Luigi lives on in our just doing doing
what he can secretly the most brave
character in the Mario universe you know
getting stuff done rescuing his friends
it's just I love the look spooky cute I
love cute spooky as an atmosphere he
just mentions always nailed that
it's it's always fun it's a great game
like I highly recommend it for this wage
we had so many other great exclusives
obviously Nintendo taking Link's
Awakening and bringing it to a modern
audience astral chain from Platten games
Mario maker to which has been
infuriating people all year long if you
watch some of the twitch streamers my
personal exclusive favorite just because
it's kind of slightly out there love
fire emblems could talk for hours about
fire in them my favorite so far has been
ring fit adventure because it kind of
picks up where we fit left off
however as somebody doesn't exercise and
I don't like the gym I find it very
intimidating being able to work out my
own home with something that's
accessible and not as clinical and
sterile as I think we fit was you know
very white a lot of scales a lot of just
kind of take it sucks all the fun out of
exercise whereas I think ring for
adventure is very accessible and just a
lot of fun and that what is it ring con
yeah yeah
like good so much resistance like I was
working I was working on last night and
this all hurts today I was doing squats
that all hurts today and it feels like
I'm actually getting a proper workout
but I don't have to deal I mean it's the
kind of the perfect bridge to get me
from not working out to actually maybe
down the line go into a gym yeah but it
sounds like from what you've told me the
workout is it could be good enough that
you wouldn't even have to go to a gym
yeah I just said a tree Hashmi yeah I
get an extreme and it and I'm someone
who does go to the gym reasonably
frequently and it's challenging enough
just because it requires different
levels of intensity it mix it up mixes
it up in a way that perhaps unless
you're very conscious of what you're
doing at a gym you may not do a lot of
people autopilot at the gym and well
this is like mixing up the exercises the
intensity how long you're doing them
it's keeping an eye on your form and
your posture and it will tell you hey
you're trying to cheat you're here and
know you're doing that or like you had
you didn't complete emotion properly and
it's doing it within the framework of an
RPG so that you don't fixate on the fact
that you're doing exercise you're just
kind of focused on playing a game and
being a boss of defeating an enemy and
at the the end result is like yesterday
I was dripping with sweat and now
brethren in the same way that I would
been like I've had personal trainer
sessions that were less intensive than
that so and those are way more expensive
another thing is you're getting a lot of
bang for your buck yeah and then and
then it integrates into your life and in
various ways and allows you to play it
or do exercise without actually engaging
with the game itself and you can like
watch some TV or you know whatever it
may be play a different game yeah which
is exactly what you do with the switch
anyway yeah exactly it's an interesting
game before we move on I do want to give
a quick shout out to fire in below oh I
don't want us to skip over Farrell's
fire rhythm genuinely was one of my
favorite games on any platform all year
just such a such a great evolution for
the series tons of customization I've
put in like over 200 hours so far I
don't want us to forget Fire Emblem
there's just a really dense game to talk
about and we don't have time to like
really break it down I think it's the
most rewarding gameplay loop of any game
I played this year yeah
hands that like constantly being
rewarded for doing things even just like
China people having relationships go up
seeing grades improve learning more
about people is its own reward but also
seeing those meters tick up it's just
every time you run into a Tabasco but
Hilda
la Hilda too so a great year for
exclusives let's talk about some ports
that maybe made it over I would say with
less success I'm thinking particularly
of overwatch here so tomorrow and I play
an obscene amount of overwatch we used
to play on PC we now play on ps4 with
different crew it's not I mean overwatch
and switch is not going to be the way I
play it's one of my favorite games of
all time it's just not the same it's
like a desperate situation I'm dying for
some overwatch right now of that
overwatch and then you find the
configuration that plays works for you
for me it was with the kickstand and
headphones and
a pro controller like crouched over it
when you when you wrote that in your
impressions I was like that is back
problems this I will sacrifice my body
for overwatch one any time but yeah it's
it's serviceable surprisingly like I
didn't expect it to be as playable as it
Oh like as enjoyable as is perhaps not
playable but once you find that thing
that works for you you do kind of feel
like yeah I'm playing a watch yeah and
you forget for a little odd that you're
playing on a switch yeah it's sketchy at
times but like when it works it
scratches the edge you get a hit that
you want out of it but yeah it's it's
not the ideal way to play but as a kind
of secondary option for when I'm out and
about and yeah witcher 3 as well it's
not gonna be the way that I play The
Witcher I played on ps4 Pro I wish I had
a PC powerful enough to have that
beautiful world as it was truly intended
it is so beautiful but I you know huge
props to CD Projekt for getting a game
of that size and scale onto something
like this which with all the dlc 2 dlc
and it's still like obviously they've
had to make some compromises to get it
on there it's still the witcher it's
like it's still 150 hour plus game on on
the go that's incredibly impressive it
it's a little muddy you don't get
bathtub girl in all his full glory maybe
but the the rest of what makes the
witcher 3 so so great is still there you
know it's it's a little different than
the overwatch situation where you're
you're missing certain
key things that make overwatch so great
but you know The Witcher it's not like
no-one's like it's so great because just
because the trees look very nice yeah I
mean I love Carol but I would say
there's lots more going for that game
besides Gerald's beauty so bathtub seems
the writing is intact is what we write
like it's not like you can the writing
is not as muddy as the visuals and also
I mean Dragon Quest though maybe
breaking that mold that one I think is
is that's where it's definitive on on
switch I mean you get you get the
orchestral soundtrack you get the I
think maybe it's 16-bit you get to kind
of like the 2d version that lets you
play the game like maybe faster than you
wouldn't 3d it's a different take on it
it looks really nice a nice screen as
well yeah it's just that that I think a
lot of people would argue it was the way
to play Dragon Quest 11 so that was a
big win for or switch ports for sure we
also had changes to switch online so
twopenny us games yep not available it's
play yeah you guys taking advantage of
that not yet I think just have decides
to have just just as a function of
having to play newer games first for
work revisiting older games is
definitely like a winter break you know
a holiday sort of activity Thanksgiving
is getting ready for game of the year
but winter break well winter break you
get it cut you can get a solid week of
playing old games that's always fun
um so I might I might dip into it then
but you know it is nice to know it's
there yeah yeah I did my regular
check-in on Super Metroid
I believe on
played maybe like three or four hours of
it and yeah it's it's for people who are
perhaps more actively engaged with
reliving nostalgia and playing classic
games it's incredibly valuable because
you know oh it's preservation yeah its
preservation it's they're doing cool
things with it they give you romhack
style kind of different variables to
game experiences that you're already
familiar with and challenge you in
different ways to player adding online
to some and you know giving providing
new opportunities to play the same games
that you may have for years and years
and years in different ways and fresh
ways and even the convenience of it like
sometimes you just feel like I want to
play a super nintendo game and it's if
it's there you're basically paying for
the online service and that's kind of
like a really nice bonus that compared
to everything else it's like maybe the
cheapest one yeah do we think
I mean clearly the tide is turning there
slowly Sun setting the 3ds it feels like
they're in Sun saying that for you yeah
it it does feel like that I think you
know I from my perspective as a Pokemon
player I would say Pokemon was kind of
like the last fashion there was still
stuff coming out on 3ds last year oh
yeah and beaker before but that was like
coming out for the week yeah I mean it's
not like it's dead I love my 3ds there
are games I'm gonna revisit on my 3ds
and I will definitely be turning it on
and transfer my Pokemon to Pokemon home
when it hopefully comes out the
beginning of next year but it it is
honestly I have a new 3ds at the right
dealer size one cuz I wanted those
faceplates it's a little hard to go back
to that screen after looking at a switch
for two years yeah
yeah I keep mine with me at all times
for Fire Emblem awakening it's always in
my bag I always have fire awakening and
I have like a 3ds I have all my pokemon
games and Fire Awakening it's very good
so I won't be getting rid of mine but I
mean at this point it makes sense to
sunset it and even now that library of
games is absolutely phenomenal I think
one of the best libraries even though
they've son said it now it's still the
perfect time buy a 3ds and invest in
that library some classic games like and
a lot of games that are now on switch in
terms of new entries in the franchise's
but still valuable to play interesting
games like fun fun fun versions of
Pokemon and Fire Emblem and Animal
Crossing and Mario and Nintendo does
have a good like shelf life on their
games okay those games ate well a lot of
the time and that's no exception but it
doesn't make sense to start pivoting
like there's games you want to see come
to if they put awakening they like made
awake like spruced it up and put it on
switch we go buckwild yes 110 we got so
in terms of sun setting the 3ds we've
also had a new version of switch
hardware we had to switch light did you
guys get one I don't have one yet
however I have I've messed around with
one because I intend on getting one I
was kind of thinking what if they
released an Animal Crossing version when
Animal Crossing comes out cuz I really
like the Animal Crossing held handhelds
they've had in the past with the 3ds but
I'm actually tempt I might just get the
be like mom this is what I want for
Christmas we still do that in my family
and I feel like I want the teal one
because it's so nice it's the for fact
area it's so much lighter literally and
it's easier you're on your poor wrists
when you're me and you're playing no
come on for hours on end or Fire Emblem
well
we'll get to that but uh it's easier on
your body I value that not having it
docked I mean I'm mostly playing my
switch handheld anyway I would never
want to get rid of the version that can
be docked like I would always think if
this is a secondary version but having
it you know when I'm at my parents house
I don't even bring my dock like I could
just bring my switch light you have a
little bit of a battery boost there the
screen is beautiful the only thing is
the the text size on some games fireable
definitely being one of them backing was
already I was already squinting to see
stuff on my regular play yeah he's
playing like I'm wearing my glasses even
though I don't really wear my glasses to
play switch that's that's one thing that
I just that's more of a I wish games had
tech size options but overall just like
a very beautiful well-made piece of
hardware and that's definitely worth
adding as a supplementary piece if if
you can afford it if that's something
you're interested in I mean Tommy is
interested just to kind of keep on at
home but I think they still need to sell
out saves that's that - you'll not clear
yeah and it's like I don't want to
invest in a piece of hardware if I'm not
completely confident in the ability to
quickly swap between the two absolutely
I mean that's my biggest hang-up is I
wish you know if it worked like ps4
saves where I was uploading it and then
downloading it and it was seamless like
that or largely seamless would be one
thing it's a little rough around the
edges on that and that's kind of a
Nintendo thing right you know that's
yeah it's kind of just how they roll
with online stuff like this so I'm not
surprised but that you know like I don't
think Animal Crossing you have class
aids that making strides not everyone's
them and it's that's gonna be the
biggest challenge to my vision of
leaving my my main switch in the dock
somewhere and taking the mini one with
me
yeah so overall how has the switches
year been for 2019 what could it do
what could Nintendo do to improve it
2020 I think it's been super solid a lot
of games that kind of redefined
franchises this year whether that's
Pokemon with us Fire Emblem even Smash
Brothers continues to be supported and
they've teased a second crop of DLC
fighters and the ones that we've had
already have been really really good so
super strong in terms of first party
games the value that you know third
parties are seeing in porting their
games over is obvious whether that's you
know we'll make it work ports like
overwatch - you know we've kept the
heart of in soul of the game intact like
Witcher but perhaps some of it around it
isn't quite working - these are just
straight-up fantastic game a fantastic
version of a game like Dragon Quest the
fact that most developers are looking at
us which bodes incredibly well for the
future of the series there's so many
certainly that platform there's so many
games that could do well on on a switch
if they were poured and now that there's
been success with that I feel like
there's got it's got bright future ahead
of it in terms of what they could do
better I think the cloud save stuff is
probably a big deal and this is
nitpicking but like considering that
we've had a bunch of fantastic games
like but still there's nothing being
quite like set the world on fire in
terms of the way that breathitt well did
I feel like Animal Crossing is gonna be
perhaps that game I hope it's gonna be
that game some reservations about I'm a
little nervous yeah but like that's
gonna be a game that a lot of people are
gonna show interest in and I feel like
it's gonna be one of the big talking
points of next year so the very least it
stands to have a one major tentpole game
next year so yeah just small nips and
tucks more than like this is you know
disaster like yeah Cali yeah I would
agree with that I think you know
Nintendo has its its big franchises but
also the switch has had so much support
from third parties and supporting indie
games having a lot of any games like I
played a lot of Baba's you once which
goose game sayonara wild hearts I played
on switch as well having that that
indeed library just just bolsters it
even more than that something that has
been really positive for the switch in
the past and so I really would like to
continue like I'd love to get like I
love to get disco Elysium on the switch
like that you know so I hope to continue
see good solid ports on switch in
addition to the major franchises and
then I would love joy contra to not be a
thing I just lost knowledge icon Detroit
country movies and in battery life
I think battery life could stand to
improve that would be like a big thing
for me as a as a version with bluetooth
for my ear pods and battery life
improvements yes completely agree yeah I
mean I'm touch would haven't been hit by
joy coin drift yet but so many people
have yeah it's kind of ridiculous that
we're two years down the line yeah it's
still happening but overall a fantastic
year for the Nintendo switch make sure
to stick around a GameSpot we'll be
revealing our game of the year 2019 on
December 17th the deliberations are
happening now it's getting all tense but
we also have report cards for Xbox
Playstation and PC so you don't wanna
miss that and thank you so much for
joining
[Music]